they think i'm weird mum
do you think i'm weird it's the dreamers
like you who change this world for the
better
[Music]
wow
[Music]
hey
[Music]
what is this place
you following us pal yeah pal he's a
human
a human
[Music]
listen up human because we're only gonna
go over this once we're sprites and this
is the everything factory
this is where we create things for the
world
trees hello the weather
even life
i love creating things i make things all
the time rabbits don't have wings mine
does you've got a lot to learn about how
the world really works human
there's something about him i can feel
it tickling my beard humans can't see
sprites but he can see me fascinating
the three of you must stay in your dorm
until further notice no ifs no butts no
coconuts
especially no coconuts
this race are pure chaos
every single thing we sprites create
this race destroyer nobody panic yeah
everybody play again
this is so adventuring
hooray
what do we do now we fight
you are
not like the others are you
there's more to you than meets the eye i
know who you are walk boy run
and who you will become
[Music]
you